I'm Nicole Carlson today I'm here to
talk about a custom pie mc3 class I
built the mimics the scikit-learn API
there's a link to my Twitter at the
bottom as well as the slides for this
talk a little bit about me
currently I'm a data scientist at shop
Runner I also teach for girls who code
on the weekends and like many people
here I'm a reformed physicist all right
here's a brief overview of the talk
first I'll do a quick motivating example
of basic linear regression and
scikit-learn I'll talk a little bit
about the pie mc3 library will do the
same linear regression example in pi MC
3 and I will compare scikit-learn and pi
MC 3 and the bulk of the talk will be
the last two bullet points implementing
a custom hierarchical logistic
regression class in PI MC 3 and then
using that class alright so to start out
with we'll do a really simple example
with scikit-learn first we're gonna
generate some fake data so we'll have
some random values for X some noise of
size 2 and then our Y values will be 4 X
plus 3 plus the noise so if we go ahead
and plot that data it looks linear which
is good because I made it alright so if
you had that data and you decided you
wanted to use scikit-learn to fit a
linear regression it's really
straightforward you instantiate a linear
regression instance you call fit on that
on your data set and you get back a fit
model once you have your train model you
can use it to predict data you can score
your model here we can see the score
this model is about 79% and we can also
plot the model in this red line and it
looks like it fits the data pretty well
once you have your train model
oftentimes you'll want to save and use
your model at a later date also very
straightforward to scikit-learn you can
just use pickle to dump your model to a
pickle file if you open it back up later
you can call score again and you see
that you get back the exact same score
this is real
the same model that you saved before
alright so I imagine most of you have
used scikit-learn before and you'll
probably agree that it's very easy and
straightforward to use
finding model parameters is really easy
predicting scoring a model as well as
saving and loading a train model all
very easy so now we can think about PI
MC 3 if you're not familiar with PI and
C 3 I'll give you a brief overview here
there's gonna be a lot a couple of other
talks about PI MC 3 that I'll probably
go more into depth of the theory but
basically it's a library for
probabilistic modeling so with this type
of modeling you parameterize your model
in some way with the linear regression
our model is a plus BX and we say that
our a and B are drawn from some
distributions that we want to discover
and there's a couple ways to determine
the distributions so one is using Markov
chain Monte Carlo samplers the way I
like to think about those is that you're
walking around in parameter space
choosing random values for the
parameters deciding whether to keep them
or not based on some cost function
another more recent method are
variational fitting algorithms so with
those you have your true distribution of
your parameters and your current
distribution and you minimize some
metric between those distributions so
one example would be the Kubla clive
Laird I've urgence between those two but
there's new algorithms coming out
basically everyday the PI MC 3 is built
on top of Theano as you may know Theano
is ending so I think they're choosing
some new back end now I don't know what
it's gonna be
and it's completely written in Python
which is why I chose it initially I
wanted to be able to go into the source
code if I ran into any problems when
you're using PI mc3 you're gonna follow
basically the same three or four basic
steps every time the first is set up you
need to parameterize your model so with
the linear regression our
parameterization
is that y is normally distributed around
some linear combination of the variables
alpha plus beta X we choose priors for
alpha and beta and we insert our
training data
the second step is inference you're
going to infer your parameters using
either MCMC sampling or variational
inference or both the third step is
interpretation you need to check your
parameter distributions and model fit
and make sure everything makes sense the
step doesn't exist in scikit-learn this
is kind of a new thing with pi mc3 and a
lot of times you'll just stop there
because what you care about is the
parameter distributions but if you want
to you can also predict data by creating
posterior samples with your inferred
parameters all right
so now we're gonna do the exact same
linear regression example but in pi mc3
so first step set up the PI MC 3 model
so the first thing you do is instantiate
a PI MC 3 model instance then we're
gonna set our model input and output is
theano shared variables this allows us
to change their values later and then we
actually parameterize the model so I'm
actually going to start at the bottom
with Y so as I was saying we our
parameterization is that our Y data is
normally distributed with a mean that is
the linear combination of our input
variables alpha plus beta X and we also
know that there's some noise s alpha
beta and s are the parameters that we
need to find the distributions for in
this case we don't know anything about
alpha and beta we just know their
numbers so one good prior distribution
for that is to say they're normally
distributed with mean 0 and standard
deviation 100 this is the point where
Bayesian modeling is really powerful if
you knew something about alpha and beta
you could put that information into the
prior distributions so if you knew alpha
was positive for some reason you could
put that right into your model our noise
s all we know is that it's positive so
we'll say that it's half normal alright
now that our model is set up we have to
infer our parameters so I actually use
add V in this case but you could also
use a sampler if you wanted to I
instantiate an instance of the advocat
and then you just
call the pi mc3 fit method telling it
how many iterations you wanted to do and
what method of inference you want more
replacements like to put different data
in as you're fitting your model in this
case I'm actually taking mini batches of
the data mini batch add V is way faster
than regular add V if you have the
opportunity to do it I highly recommend
using it a model that are trained went
from like eight hours to like 20 minutes
many batches also help you avoid local
maximum so once your model has been fit
with add V you're gonna look at
something called the evidence lower
bound or elbow which is helpfully stored
in this property called hist for some
reason in PI MC 3 not sure why and you
can graph that to see if your model has
converged so what you want to see is
that the elbow starts out at some lower
value and then converges to some higher
value which we see here okay so now we
need to interpret our parameters so our
advocate is giving us an approximation
of the parameter distributions I don't
know about you but if you just tell me
parameters distributed with some mean
and standard deviation I'm not
necessarily gonna know what that means
so since we're Bayesian when in doubt
sample so we're gonna sample from our
parameter distributions and we can just
call a sample on our approximation tell
it how many draws to take and then that
gives us a trace of our parameter values
with that trace PI MC 3 has some great
functions to help you interpret those
one of them is summary so summary gives
you this nice printout of each variable
main standard deviations other things
you might want to know another nice
function is called trace pot this is one
I use the most often so the trace plot
for each variable you have a normalized
histogram on the left and on the right
side is a time series of the parameter
values so since we are just sampling
from our parameter distribution it
doesn't really change that much over
time if this was samples from an MC MC
sampler you would see that they would
start at 0 and then go to the final
value
in this case which looks to be around
three and if you were called the data
from earlier it was y equals three plus
4x with some size 2
so you can see that our model really is
picturing up the structure of the data
okay
so like I said in a lot of cases you
found the parameters might just stop but
if you want to predict new data you can
create create posterior predictive
samples by using the sample PPC method
from PI MC 3 tell it what trace to use
what model to use and how many samples
you want so in this case I want 2000
samples this means that for each Y data
point I have 2000 samples so we can look
at this here the red is the true data
point and the blue smears are the 2000
samples for each data point so unlike
with scikit-learn linear regression
you're not just getting a point estimate
you are getting a bunch of estimates for
each data point that may not be useful
for you so one thing you can do is just
take the mean of all these samples and
use that as a point estimate so the the
means are shown here in green but you
still have all this other data so if for
some reason you wanted to know the
uncertainty of your values you could
take the standard deviation and do
something with that if you wanted to
once we have point estimates we can also
just call score the R to score on this
data and you can see this model is also
at about 79% accuracy so we're getting
the same performance that psych it
learns linear regression did which is
good all right so as I was learning PI
MC 3 I ran into a few issues along the
way most PI MC three examples only exist
in Jupiter notebooks which is really
awesome when you're talking to other
data scientists but when you try to
production lies a model I found that
engineers do not like Jupiter notebooks
no matter how well you comment them I
tried giving one to some engineers and
they were just like what is this most
examples also focus on training a model
one data set and don't demonstrate how
to predict new data
it may not be obvious to you from the
simple example we've just seen how you
would actually put in a training or
testing data set and they definitely
don't show you how to save your model
for later use it's not like scikit-learn
where you just pickle the model itself
so the spoiler alert is that what you
want to save is the trace you don't need
to save the pie mc3 model instance you
can always recreate that later so if we
compare the two libraries everything's
still easy and scikit-learn 5c3
things are a little harder I would say
finding model parameters is a medium
difficulty once you parameterize your
problem you can relatively easily find
the parameters by running inference
predicting new data and scoring a model
are more difficult you have to figure
out how to swap your data in and out and
saving and loading a trained model
basically seem impossible when you're
first starting out until you find that
one Stack Overflow answer that's like
five answers down alright so if you're
like my boss you look at this and you're
like why would I ever use PI mc3 so I
added in an extra row so I can learn has
a limited number of model types
available they're very strict about what
makes it into their API the algorithms
have to be really well tested it has to
meet their code requirements on the
other hand with PI MC 3 the model types
you can build are very broad basically
if you can parameterize it you should be
able to infer the parameters so you can
end up doing a lot more than when you
can which is scikit-learn itself so
here's what I want to reproduce in PI MC
3 I want a class where I can just call
fit predict score save and load without
having to think about all the details
just like I do a scikit-learn so in
order to do that this is the mapping
between scikit-learn and PI MC 3 the
fit-step
in pine in scikit-learn corresponds to
setup in PI M C 3 and the inference step
predict and score are the same the
forstuff predict data save and load is
going to be something new with time C 3
and time C 3 also has this additional
interpretation step that you don't
really have with scikit-learn
all right so now we're gonna get into
even more code I'm going to show you a
custom hierarchical logistic regression
class I implemented in PI and c3 if
you're not familiar with hierarchical
models this is a type of model you would
use if your data comes in some type of
categories so for example if you had a
bunch of algebra score scores for tests
for high school students one level of
your hierarchy might be the individual
students and another level might be the
teachers themselves so maybe the teacher
that a student has has some effect on
how well they do on their test probably
true all right as I was creating my
custom class I noticed that a number of
the properties and methods I wrote were
not specific to this particular model so
I decided to create a Bayesian model
base class for reusable components the
base class has two methods inference and
set shared values set shared values just
calls the Theano set value function on
the-- our shared variables the child
class has to implement the following
methods create model fit predict and
score okay so now we can dig into the
code so first step initializing the HLR
class you can see that this child HLR
class calls the parent bayesian model
class the parent bayesian model class in
turn causes scikit-learn base estimator
class this means that you should be able
to use this class with your favorite
scikit-learn transformers in a pipeline
grid search all the things you know and
love and we can look at the properties
that are in this initialization so one
is the add B history lose another is the
add V trace we will save a cache model
the number of predictors and the theano
shared variables so these are things
that every Bayesian model needs to save
and the child HLR class in addition will
have this property that's the number of
categories so if you have some different
child class they might have other
properties they need to say
all right so now we'll get into fit it's
a big wall of code but don't worry we're
gonna walk through it all so if we look
at this fit function you see it starts
out just like scikit-learn
you put in your X of Y data and
additionally we have the categories for
our data the last two keyword arguments
are for inference and I'll explain them
in a second as we go through so if we
walk through this code first thing we do
pull out the number of categories the
number of predictors pretty
straightforward let me check if there's
a cash by MC 3 model and if not we'll
create that model and this method is one
of the child class methods and I'll show
you that in a second once we have our
cash model we need to create
mini-batches
for the inference so that's what I'm
doing here and you can specify the batch
size using the batch size argument once
we have our mini batches we just call
the parent inference method because
again it doesn't depend on anything
about the child class and you can also
tell it how many iterations you want it
to run so now we'll look at the create
model method this corresponds to step 1
set up the model and one thing to note
is that it doesn't take in any of the
data XY or categories and again that's
because what you really need to save is
the trace once you have a trace you can
set up a new PI mc3 model and use it
with that so if we walk through this
should look relatively similar to the
linear regression example first thing we
do is set up some Theano shared
variables model input output and
additional me other categories then
we're just going to throw those into a
dictionary I mean Stan she ate our PI MC
3 model and again I'm gonna jump to the
bottom and work my way up so since this
is logistic regression our output is
true false so these will be the results
of a Bernoulli distribution with the
parameter that's the inverse logistic of
the
linear combination of the variables
alpha plus beta X the difference in this
case is that each alpha and beta depends
on what category the data is in
so you can see we have one alpha per
category and one beta per category poor
predictor since this is a hierarchical
model we want to show that all the
alphas are related together and the
betas so the way we do that is by
defining these type of parameters Mu
Alpha Sigma Alpha Mu Beta Sigma Beta and
these are the means and standard
deviations of the Alpha and Beta values
just like with linear regression we
don't have that much knowledge about the
hyper parameters so we'll say the means
are normally distributed and standard
deviations are half normally distributed
and again if we had some prior knowledge
we could put that in here all right so
now we have our PI mc3 model and I'll
show you the inference step that fit
called so this is the parent class
method imprints just takes in the
mini-batches and the number of
iterations you want to run just like
linear regression we're gonna
instantiate an instance of the add V
inference call fit number of iterations
the method we want to use in the
mini-batches don't worry about callbacks
that has to do with convergence once we
ever fit I'm gonna again draw some
samples of the parameters and also save
the abbé hist bell use all right I call
this inference this is in particular
mini-batch add V you could imagine
implementing other forms of inference if
that was better suited for your problem
all right since this is logistic
regression our output is true false but
we may wish to know the probability of
the data being true or false so just
like scikit-learn I implemented a
predict probabilities method so I also
called it predict problem should look
relatively similar to second learn takes
into X and again additionally we have
the categories for this type of data
I'll talk about the last argument in a
second but if we go through the first
thing it does is check if there's an add
V trace if there's not then I raise this
custom error telling you to run fit on
the model before predict and to
reiterate again it's
because the trace is what's really
important and what you need to save with
your model once we ensure that we have a
trace we give it our samples and let me
check if there's a cache model in this
case it doesn't matter if there's a
cache model or not because if there's
not we just create a new one
all right because we'll be using that
same model with our existing trace we
call the parents set shared Tver
method to set the Theano shared
variables with our input data and then
we can just call a sample PPC as we did
before telling it what trace to use what
model and how many samples we want so
again we have 2000 samples for data
point so we could just take the mean if
we want to or you may wish to have both
the mean and the standard deviations
returned if you want a measure some
uncertainty in your predictions all
right predicts pretty straightforward
just calls predict prabha gets the
probabilities and then checks if they're
greater there's then some threshold in
this case point 5 if you wanted to make
it more general you could change this
method so that it takes in a custom
threshold all right score takes in X Y
just like scikit-learn and additionally
we have these categories then it just
uses the scikit-learn
accuracy score function and calculates
the accuracy score based on your
predictions all right so now we're at
saving and loading so the child class in
this case has some extra parameters it
wants to save the number of categories
the number of predictors so it puts
those in a dictionary and sends those
and calls the parent classes save method
the parent classes save method takes in
a folder where you want to save your
stuff and then uses job Lib to save the
abbé trace and any custom parameters to
that folder so pretty straightforward
load basically does the exact opposite
of that the child class calls the parent
load first and then gets back the
parameters and puts those in the
properties and the parent load class
just loads the abbé trace from whatever
folder you tell it to as well as any
custom parameters and that was all the
code so that was how I built my custom
class now I can show you how you can
actually use this class so even if you
didn't follow all the code you would
still be able to use this class just
like you wouldn't scikit-learn so just
like before we're gonna generate some
fake data in this case we have two
predictors and two categories I'm
setting you alpha and Sigma Alpha equal
to 5 and mu beta Sigma Beta equal to 10
because I didn't want to bother sampling
for those so these are again are the
hyper parameters in our model and then
we're gonna sample for alpha and beta
from those distributions
so here are two alphas and our four
betas so once we have those values we
can generate some fake x data and then
use that to generate the Y data by just
taking the linear combination of the
values and sitting it through an inverse
logistic and then through a binomial so
in this case I generated each category
separately and then just concatenate
edit everything together and our
categories are just labeled zero and one
in this case alright so now we have some
fake data and we decide we want to fit
in HLR to this so I load the class from
my custom library PS toolkit I
instantiate an instance and now if I
want to train a model I can just call
fit and put in my XY categories and in
this case I wanted to change the default
arguments and now I have a trained HLR
model so with that model I can predict
and score
so here I can use predict Prabha to
generate some probabilities of for each
data point I can also get back true
false predictions and I can score our
model so you can see it's doing about
98% accuracy all right if I want to save
and load the model later again I set it
up so that's really straightforward just
call save and tell it where you want to
keep your stuff these are pickles so
they're in a pickle jar and if I want to
use this later I instantiate a new
instance in my class tell it where the
stuff is saved
and we can go ahead and run score again
you see it's also add about 98% accuracy
it's not the exact same because we're
sampling every time so this isn't like
scikit-learn where you're gonna get the
exact same result do the sampling you're
likely to get slightly different answers
but if your sample enough that all
should wash out
all right so if you were following along
you may have noticed I skipped a step in
the pie mc3 process which is
interpreting your parameters but I built
some extra methods into the class to
allow you to easily do that as well so
one is this plot elbow function this is
a parent class method that just plots
the elbow for you so you can see if your
fit has convergent or not since we saved
the trace as a property you can just
call those same PI mc3 functions either
summary or get this nice printout so
here I'm showing you the alphas and
betas again and we can compare them
against the tray spot so the alphas are
at like 7 and 11 looks like it's heading
that way to 13 18 22 yeah looks like
it's heading in the right direction
so the model really is picturing picking
up some of the structure and the data
the me office and the musee des are not
doing as well but maybe I could change
some stuff to get them to work so it's
still really easy to interpret the
parameters with this custom class as
well so hopefully you'll agree that
everything with my custom class is
easy-to-find model parameters you just
have to call fit to predict new data
just call predict score call score their
save and load methods so as long as you
know where you want to keep your stuff
it's easy and it's also really
straightforward to interpret the
prioritization so the last thing I want
to talk about are some next steps you
may have noticed that I hard-coded a lot
of values in it's cuz I'm lazy but if I
wanted to I could use the add those as
keyword arguments that you could pass in
to the various methods to make this even
more generalizable as I mentioned I only
implemented mini-batch ad V there are
tons of other types of inference that
you could implement and maybe let the
end-user decide which method is best for
their problem and again since this is
built on a psychic learned based
estimator you should be able to use this
in a psychic learning pipeline so I
would want to test that in my imaginary
free time alright
so that's basically it I wanted to thank
my co-workers at shop runner who helped
me and gave me a lot of advice on this
we're hiring in Chicago you should come
work with us because I'm awesome
obviously I gave a version of this talk
at PI T to Chicago in June so I want to
thank the community there for giving me
feedback as well as my former co-workers
at shift gig who also helped me practice
here's a link to the slides again as
well as the code for the custom HLR
class thank you
[Applause]
I've done that in other classes but not
this one so yes if I just wanted a point
estimate I would do that yes so he asked
if you could just save they add the
approximation instead of the trace yeah
you could definitely do that you you
would save space but you would also lose
on time because it takes a while to do
those samples yeah
the question was about using pi MC
backends like what like a sequel light
and stuff like that I ran into trouble a
sequel light because I had too many
variables and they have a limit on the
number of columns so I gave up I gave up
on those yeah I just picked all the
traces so I'm not sure what you mean
I'm not sure it was about compiling
Theano
Santo caches that from the front row
cool thank you
[Music]
[Applause]